[Music]
on this sunday night
an adventure turns deadly in alberta a
tour bus rolls over
in the rocky mountains you could
definitely see if people were crouched
over the windows helping people out how
a scenic trip to a glacier turned tragic
the mandatory mask debate heats up as
anti-massacres raised their voices
plus kids and covid19 this is not just
an infectious disease crisis
the pandemic poses a different threat to
children in the u.s
and this big guy is for sale everybody
loves theater what the future holds for
halifax harbor's most famous face
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
our nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us one of the most beautiful drives in
the country
is now the scene of a tragedy three
people have been killed
14 are fighting for their lives in
hospital after a tour bus rolled over in
jasper national park the custom-designed
sightseeing bus
offering visitors an edge off the ice
thrill was driving the columbia ice
fields located 100 kilometers
south of jasper 27 people were on board
the big rig
ice explorer as it traveled from a
visitor center
along the side of highway 93 when it
rolled down
an embankment because of covet 19 the
boss was at 50
capacity global's jamie dahl is
following developments from the scene of
the rollover tonight
jamie well people travel from all around
the world to see
and explore the iconic columbia ice
fields it's a highlight in a trip to the
rockies
but all that excitement shattered by
tragedy and now sorrow for so many
families
i took my camera and zoomed as far as it
would go and i'm like
yeah it is wheels up so i could see even
more stuff at that point and realized
they were still getting people out
and i was shocked at that point to
realize this has just happened
just an hour after she stepped off one
of these buses angela bye watched from a
distance crews scrambling to rescue 27
people
involved in a rollover while riding in
an ice explorer
you could definitely see if people were
crutched over the windows helping people
out
there were a couple of people in helmets
it must have been some of the first
people who got up there
coming to help out the impact really hit
more when we were driving away and we
were seeing emergency vehicle after
emergency vehicle after emergency
vehicle come down the road
and ask knowing what it was going for
the site is now blocked off while police
pieced together what happened turned
away tourists now steer their focus to
the dot on the horizon
parthbala drove 36 hours from toronto to
see the glaciers
a trip he's been planning for nearly a
decade he's still
keen to go in a statement the tour
company's president
says i would like to extend our deepest
condolences to the family and friends of
the deceased
as well as extend her utmost sympathy to
those who were injured
angela bye says there are no seat belts
in the buses but she felt safe
and says she would do it again it is a
tragedy what happened
and stuff but i'm hoping that we'll just
remember the gorgeous stuff that we saw
beforehand
now the rcmp parks canada and
occupational health and safety remain on
scene
investigating the names of those killed
have not been released
but due to the travel restrictions the
majority of tourists who have been
coming here
have been canadians pharah
that is jamie dahl thank you jamie to
ottawa where blockable
leader eve francois blanchette hit back
against an anonymous
sexual misconduct allegation dating back
to 1999.
walchette spoke only in french saying he
has never
acted the way that has been alleged and
claiming the accusation was
politically and ideologically motivated
he affirmed that he does not
plan to step aside as leader of the
party blochette's fellow black quebecois
mps also released a statement of support
today saying
we are convinced the anonymous
allegations made against him are false
and we support him without hesitation
it's the first time blochette has faced
the media
since the allegations from an
unidentified woman appeared in a
facebook group last week
walchette demanded the facebook group
remove what he calls
a defamatory post
another issue continues to cause
controversy tonight
the debates surrounding face masks and
forcing people to wear them as covet 19
continues to spread
the approach is different from province
to province and there is mixed reaction
right across our country while most
people understand the reasons for
wearing masks
today a movement against mandatory face
coverings held protests
in major centers in canada julia foy
reports
a visit to a montreal tim hortons turned
ugly when police officers had to wrestle
a man to the ground
after he refused to wear a mask
a new mandatory mask mandate in quebec
means shop owners must ensure customers
wear one
or face fines we're of course not asking
merchants to physically
get into a scuffle with with someone who
wouldn't comply
so in that case they call the police to
ask for the person to be expelled
there were several anti-mask protests
across the country this weekend
as the debate continues over whether
masks should be mandatory
you telling me that you actually lied to
us back in april but now i'm supposed to
believe you
it's a joke we should be allowed to
choose what we want to do with our
bodies
although health officials did not
promote general mass use early in the
pandemic
things have changed scientists believe
that wearing masks
can help curb the spread of covet 19.
but if you're indoors
you can't guarantee that the air is
moving really
uh well and if it is aerosol you can get
a much higher
dose and in that situation it's good to
keep that stuff
out right now the rules vary from
province to province
quebec a covid19 hotspot just made
wearing masks
mandatory in all indoor public places as
cases surge
in toronto face coverings are also
required in public spaces
in nova scotia they're mandatory on
public transit
elsewhere in the maritimes and western
provinces masts are not mandatory
but they are recommended on transit
inside public facilities
and where physical distancing can't be
followed masks are safe to
wear they do not cause you to become
hypoxic
they do not increase your risk of of
keeping viruses or bacteria or other
things in
you know they do not exacerbate asthma
or other lung conditions experts say
wearing a mask
may ensure you can still enjoy your
phase 3 freedoms
julia foy global news vancouver
u.s president donald trump says he's
against making americans wear face masks
in public
despite a surging death toll in his
country that is far
outpacing estimates 140 000 americans
have now died of covet 19
and close to half a million people
tested positive in just
one week but now the president says
those statistics from america's top
health agency
are false here's jennifer johnson
as the u.s reports over 70 000 new cases
of covet 19 a day
president donald trump says he will not
support a nationwide mask
mandate i want people to have a certain
freedom and i don't
believe in that no and i don't agree
with the statement that if everybody
wear a mask everything
disappears the president's own health
experts including cdc director dr robert
redfield
dr anthony fauci the nation's top
infectious disease expert
and others have repeatedly said cases of
the virus will significantly decrease
if everyone wears a mask we're capable
of figuring out what to do
if we want to see this current surge and
it's a real surge
to turn around all americans need to
recognize it's up to us
wear a mask when you're out of your
house in an interview with fox news
sunday the president again
criticized fauci and others for quote
being wrong about the virus
because i've been right probably more
than anybody else
and he disputed figures from johns
hopkins university that america's per
capita kobit 19 mortality rate
is the seventh highest in the world you
have the numbers please
because i heard we had the best
mortality rate meanwhile as schools
debate reopening
sobering news that no child at any age
is safe from the virus
85 infants in one texas county have
tested positive
in arizona and florida death tolls are
the highest ever
the residents here are terrified and
i'm terrified for the first time in my
career
because there's a lack of leadership
even senate republicans are battling the
president
some in his own party are pushing back
against a white house attempt to block
billions for more testing and contract
tracing
as their constituents demand an end to
this crisis
jennifer johnson global news washington
even in the u.s the top food producing
country in the world
the virus is fueling a hunger emergency
food insecurity has nearly doubled
during the pandemic
and it is even worse for racialized
americans and children
federal relief benefits have barely
covered the basics and as reggie chikini
explains those funds
are about to run out far from the
emergency rooms where kovid 19's tool is
painfully visible
the effects of the virus are being felt
in millions of homes across america
this is not just an infectious disease
crisis it's about whether or not people
will survive
and thrive as the economy started to
shrink
paychecks disappeared leaving millions
of families to face a second crisis
hunger those struggling most in the u.s
are the essential workers in health care
food services
and front line industries those
individuals have to stand up for their
rights to protect themselves at the same
time that social inequality
lands them in underpaid under-resourced
jobs the virus has indirectly targeted
minority communities who already face
unique health challenges
10 of the counties struggling most in
america are 60 percent black
but new data shows of the roughly 17
percent of households struggling to feed
their kids
25 percent are hispanic and 30 percent
are black
an issue that impacts less than 10
percent of white families
food insecurities appears to have
doubled among the general population
and also among kids it appears to be one
out of four when food supplies are short
schools often shoulder the burden in the
united states
30 million children get at least one
meal a day at school
if we're not continuing to feed them the
way that we have been
that could be horrible i mean you can
give them the device but if they're
hungry they're not learning
a pandemic benefit was issued by the
government to nearly 38 million
americans
currently on food stamps right now the
maximum benefit is 646 dollars for a
family of four in a given month
and that is widely recognized to be
inadequate that benefit is set to expire
in a matter of weeks and a fourth
stimulus bill that includes food
assistance
has stalled in the u.s senate making
sure that people can support themselves
feed
house themselves educate their children
all of those things can make a
difference in the long term
the non-partisan congressional budget
office says economic recovery from covet
could take a decade another devastating
blow for families unsure
of where their next meal comes from
reggie shakini global news washington
600 000 people have now died of covet 19
around the world and the world health
organization says the spread is still
accelerating what's happening in hong
kong and australia where cases are
surging again has caught everyone off
guard
and as redmond shannon reports in europe
the political side effects of this
pandemic
could also be long long-lasting four
weeks ago it looked like australia might
be close to
eliminating covet 19. that seems like a
long time ago now
there are 5 696 cases of chronovirus in
victoria that's 363 new cases
since yesterday the reopening of
australia's parliament has been delayed
as the country scrambles to deal with
the resurgence of the virus
we are going to be wearing masks in
victoria and potentially in other parts
of
other parts of the country for a very
long time in locked down melbourne
anyone outside their home could soon be
fined two hundred dollars
for not wearing a mask similar mask
rules and a similar second wave are
playing out in hong kong chief executive
kari lam says the situation
is critical and not under control the
city has seen its highest number of
daily cases
since the start of the pandemic south
africa
is now also a hot spot of the virus but
a lack of testing in
other african countries means it's
difficult to track the spread across the
continent
on sunday nigeria's foreign minister
revealed that
he's tested positive the european union
is now focusing on
economic recovery but the virus is still
a major threat to health
and to eu stability i don't know what is
the personal
reason for the dutch prime minister to
hate me or hungary
but he is attacking so harshly a small
group of richer nations
including the dutch demand stricter
terms on a one
trillion dollar rescue package and
guarantees on democratic freedoms from
countries like poland
and hungary the best way what we can do
to give the money to those
who are in need and help them to spend
it as much
and as soon as they can just six months
after brexit
the eu desperately needs to show unity
at a time of crisis
redmond shannon global news london
[Music]
next coronavirus and rural communities
coming up the barriers to covenanting
care in saskatchewan and still ahead a
fiery protest
and fresh escalation as unidentified
officers
round up demonstrators why the mayor of
portland oregon
is asking federal agents to leave now
[Music]
ominous skies over ontario as a summer
storm moves across the province
tornado warnings have now been lifted
but the risk of severe thunderstorms
remains in some areas
strong winds frequent lightning and
torrential rain emerged after a cold
front mixed with ontario's intense
humidity
power outages affected over 30 000
customers across the province
there are winds of change in
saskatchewan where some areas have been
able to get their outbreaks of covet 19
under control but challenges remain in
remote
rural areas from testing to stopping
transmission
global's roberta bell has been digging
into a story on canadian pandemic life
we rarely see roberta farah saskatchewan
has not escaped the novel coronavirus
it's just looked different here
much of the population lives in rural
parts of the province in areas like this
and they've been the hardest hit we have
seen and we continue to see
local outbreaks that show just how
quickly this virus can spread
the province is now facing its second
major rural outbreak and with it
new challenges in providing care this
time to members of affected hutterite
colonies
throughout the work with hutterite
colonies in the southwest and west
central we
have been bringing staff on colony when
invited we haven't showed up unannounced
inherent barriers to testing to contact
tracing and from
all angles testing has been a big
challenge
in the rural areas to get members
redeployed
because you know it only stands to
reason that the concentration of
registered nurses in the rural areas is
far less
than what it is in urban areas regina
and saskatoon
were about half of the population of
saskatchewan lives
the southwest and west central
communities are at risk right now
but a month and a half ago all eyes were
on the indigenous communities in the
lockdown northwest
when we only have one road in like okay
it's never gonna make you weird
but covid19 did make it into the home of
this family of fifteen
with multiple bedrooms and two bathrooms
they managed to isolate from each other
still darren poorman's wife wanda became
infected
and the nearest hospital when the family
needed it was hours away
there were some similar challenges in
the northern village of lalosh
the epicenter of that outbreak but as of
this week
the community eradicated the
to be at virus and just
take a day or two to enjoy that and then
get back to work and
figure out what we're gonna do for the
next wave as of sunday more new cases in
the central region
but only four a glimmer of hope for the
area in its battle against the corona
virus
roberta bell global news
still ahead the standoff between
protesters police and
unidentified federal agents in portland
this is the portland police bureau this
is a residential area
an escalation of protests in portland
oregon after fire erupted at a police
union building
for weeks mostly peaceful demonstrators
have come out against police brutality
specifically federal agents deployed by
the trump administration
who were no badges or name tags the
masked
camouflaged federal officers have been
rounding up demonstrators
even using tear gas and batons on them
at least 13
protesters have been arrested portland's
mayor and oregon's governor have
denounced the crackdowns authoritarian
tactics and are demanding
they leave the city syrians went to the
polls today to elect a new parliament
under strict pandemic protocols
it's the third legislative vote in syria
since its deadly civil war began in
march of
four hundred thousand people have died
in the conflict
and more than half of the country's
population has been displaced
with no real opposition to the party of
strongman bashar al-assad
the vote is being called a quote
theatrical election
by critics
star for sale next and you lease on the
life-sized icon
in halifax
a canadian ship that's harbored decades
of fame
is up for sale for the right price you
could be the owner of theodore the
tugboat
made famous by the popular children's
show but as jesse thomas reports people
in halifax are determined to keep the
tourist attraction
in atlantic waters you might recognize
theodore the tugboat from the hugely
popular children's program that aired
for five seasons in canada
and internationally when you look at
theater's big smiling face everybody
loves theater loves to take their
picture by theodore theodore tugboat was
the brainchild of canadian television
producer andrew cochran
the show spun into a book deal there
were toys and memorabilia
even its own children's clothing line
then came the real life theodore 2 the
tugboat
designed and built in 2000 the vessel
has been navigating the waters in
halifax harbor ever since
greeting cruise ships and operating as a
tour boat but not this year
with covid 19 the tourism industry is
hurting and that meant the tugboat had
to be put up for sale to stay afloat
it isn't translating into economic
return for us so
we've been subsidizing theodore for for
the recent years
with a price tag of 495 000
the 65 foot 105 ton vessel
could be yours it's never actually been
used as a tugboat
but it can be there may be other uses
for it too be it a ferry be it a cafe
an airbnb there's there's so many
potentials it's a halifax icon but the
theodore 2 has toured waters outside
halifax gaining international
recognition it's gone to boston new york
philadelphia
baltimore fort lauderdale and even as
far as miami
despite its international acclaim
campbell hopes the tugboat can be
purchased locally so it's kept in the
halifax harbor
it seems residents do too the vessel has
tugged their heartstrings well hopefully
someone in the province
buys it and then we can keep it in our
harbor
because it's such a great attraction for
kids and families and everyone that
comes to visit halifax a gofundme
campaign has emerged
anna cook grew up watching theodore
tugboat and said she couldn't let this
beloved part of halifax waterfront just
disappear
halifax is definitely its home and it's
gonna be unfortunate to like go into the
harbor
not be able to see his smiling face some
people think he's creepy but i think
it's quirky and fun
the gofundme has raised nearly a
thousand dollars in counting
cook hopes to raise enough money to buy
theodore and donate the tugboat to the
maritime museum of the atlantic
jesse thomas global news halifax it's
hard not to smile looking at that face
and that is global national for sunday
i'm farah nasser tonight's your canada
is main
island bc home of the georgina point
heritage park
and lighthouse built in 1885. does your
community have a unique
landmark you'd like to share with us
email your pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks so much for watching until
tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
[Applause]
you